if something is false he calls it out
even if it means alienating the entire
medical community he doesn't care he
cares about the truth Marlon Perkins put
my father on this path early on that's
ultimately what led to my father making
the discovery many many years later I
have cystic fibrosis
I was excited to help kids with system
of ulcers
and they fired me he's never been tied
to a certain set of research or a food
company or a drug company or the dollar
he's just then committed to his heart
and what he knew they would actually
follow us and hand out petitions and
they actually had people arrested it was
quite the fight him back in the early
days he's not gonna be stopped by the
FDA no one wants to take on the FDA they
said no one wants to go through that
battle I've seen my father deal with a
lot of blows that would cause most
people to just curl up in a ball and
quit I don't care if he gets knocked
down another 20 times he will get up
that 20 first time I give lectures all
over the world people every month bump
to me and tell me I saved their lives
how the information saved their mother
how to save their kids you can't pay for
that you cannot pay for that that's
worth everything
[Music]
Wow dad 20 years 20 years
could you imagine that we'd be here
tonight 20 years ago well I actually had
a great story about that but who knows
who knew here we are
did you but no honestly I mean can you
give us the short version did you really
believe 20 years ago and I came down in
my 4runner with my sister my
brother-in-law my - we need augs and a
baby that it would lead to this well I
was asked that question 24 years ago 24
years ago how big do you think you're
gonna get they said well we want to get
and take over the biggest network
marketing companies in the world these
people because we needed to we needed to
build an army to get this information
out just to save kids that was the whole
idea and we needed an army one little
short guy couldn't do it by himself so I
needed an army and it's time to call in
the cavalry and these people were all
kind of Union people and they fell on
their back and laughed and kicked in the
air and laughed and laughed and laughed
you know today these same killers said
remember what he said we believe you now
[Applause]
so over that 20 years over the last 20
years of youngevity you know I was asked
what things really stand out has like
just amazing moments or accomplishments
and things and you know what what really
stands out to me is as a major
accomplishment of this company what sets
this company apart from other direct
selling companies are the FDA health
claim petitions and you really drove
those obviously with Jonathan E mord's
help and and all of that but I mean as
Michelle said in that video nobody wants
to to go up against the FDA and you
didn't bat an eye you didn't blink why
why was that important to get that
health freedom information or that
health information out and maintain
health freedom to you I was that so
important well number one when you know
how to save kids with the discovery of
the Z like cystic fibrosis muster
dystrophy these sort of things and you
get fired for it you know that the
system really isn't in it for the truth
and so sometimes you just have to be
like David out of the Bible and just get
in there and go after the big boys no
matter what and that's what I was gonna
require that's what we were gonna do
and if I may I'll throw this in when we
started after I got fired we started a
little company and we were doing great
and we wanted to go public those back
then and Arthur Andersen big auditor you
know auditing company we him come in to
audit us so he could go public this is
just before this is like a couple of
months for we started youngevity and
they fired me again because they wanted
my money I was a distributor is very
successful it's true I was making a big
six-figure income every month and so
this guy wanted my money and so they got
me fired and we had our first meeting in
Santa Cruz California is it six months
later and it was all based on radio and
getting information out and people were
coming by the hundreds to come to this
meeting but nobody was coming in the
door because the Arthur Andersen
employees had hired three guys were all
over 250 pounds each to turn people away
and say the meetings been canceled and
so I had to say to the guy who is
hosting the meeting who whether it was
Clint Eastwood's driver and I said you
have deal I said deal we need the
cavalry I can take one of those I can't
take three of them by myself I said I
want you to call 911 get five squad cars
here tell them there's gonna be a riot
there's me deaths everywhere we need
five squad cars when men armed to the
teeth and I just prayed that he
remembered the message so I took on the
guy in the middle who was passing out
the papers and we were on the ground
fighting these other two were kicking me
and the ribs broke all my ribs on this
side gave me a concussion and here come
the five squad cars
thank you Jesus and thank you do they
cuffed him and to make a long story
short we sued him in federal court
shortly thereafter on the RICO law such
a racketeering they were trying to
destroy us physically so they could take
over our company and they settled out of
court in federal court they settled and
that's the sigmaii we got to start yeah
so tell our audience a little bit about
how dead doctors don't like aim to be
did you did you sit down did you script
it out
was it over a period of years how did
dead doctors don't lie how did how did
that come okay
well basically I was out giving lectures
and the sort of chapters for the Cystic
Fibrosis Foundation we're having me come
and lecture locally because they wanted
to know what was going on in 1978 19
1978 I was working for Emory University
and the Yerkes primate Center that's
where I made the discovery and they're
the ones that fired me in Georgia and so
giving these lectures in 2020 is
following us one of these days you're
going to see this we actually Steve
finally tracked it down got the video
from the 20/20 interviews I did back in
those days and we're doing these things
and it became apparent that we needed
this one we needed the army and began to
create things that were sort of pre-made
that everybody needed and throw in a
secret sauce for the various diseases
and I know I'm getting off track here
[Music]
let's try to bring it to 1980 something
well that that audio was recorded in
this in 93 yes no yes but I know you had
been lecturing obviously all along up to
that point but okay so I actually had
you know retired US making good money I
retired and moved down to Houston Texas
where I met mallanna huh Sugarland
Sugarland
and I kept going to the medical library
and living with see Jeremiah on the boat
called the elixir we were living on this
boat out in the lake and in Houston
Texas and I went in and you know is
dawning on me that people are there
everything they always say I got to ask
my doctor you're dying you're on 14 per
scripts of medications I got to ask my
doctor about this nutrition and says
well how good are doctors really how
good are they how long do they live so
while I was in the medical school
library there in Houston Texas Texas
Medical Center I just grabbed a whole
arm load of the journal the American
Medical Association put on the table I
went to the obituaries pages I just took
the first 200 obituaries added up the
age and then divided by 200 I got 58 58
that's the average lifespan in medical
doctors America so I did it the other
way took the other end and I went 200
handed up and got 57.9 okay 58 and so I
started making photocopies of these
obituaries of doctors and handing about
it means but why are you going to these
guys look at that they're dying in 58
and there was a football player who had
a kid with a mustard issue from Seattle
Washington in Seattle he honks he's
playing for I was having a meeting down
in Florida and he flies all the way from
Seattle down to Florida and I'm handing
out these obituaries and doctors you
know I love the ones who were sports
medicine doctors dying of a heart attack
while they're doing a marathon at age 35
cardiologist dying of a heart attack
while they were in surgery those kind of
stuff and so I'm handing these
obituaries out and this guy got it he's
big and we were in this auditorium with
metal chairs and he started throwing
these metal chairs around this big
300-pound football player like David
ruts his size right needs thrown stuff
around and is very noisy and very loud
and everybody the 80 people were in
there huddling in the corner Ben fear
for their lives I said well can I help
you
he says I want to know why you're
handing out obituaries of doctors and
I'm here
find out how to save my son with mustard
SP and I don't know where it came from
but out of my mouth came only dead
doctors don't lie Wow
so you went onto the radio
started the radio 23 years ago you
shared the dead doctors don't lie
lecture I would say you know we do
monologue based on the newspaper stories
on health that day or that week it was
the complete stranger that recorded it
made it into an audio cassette no is
actually one of our distributors um
let's see Barbara from Kansas City was
actually recorded in Kansas City yeah
and it was just my regular lecture and
she was a horse woman she had all these
horses and one of the guys who worked
for a group was by the name they called
it the committee for against medical
fraud and they they dogged me they filed
a lot of course you know you know who
I'm talking about these bad guys
Jonathan Jon Renner and Victor Herbert's
and Stephen Barrett and everything and
Barbara she's a big woman she's six foot
three couple hundred pounds and we're up
lecturing there where I actually made
made this recording and he's handing out
papers saying that I'm a quack and don't
listen to me and everything we're in
there like the third floor me room and
she picks him up by the belt mother
truck for the neck and throws him down
three flights of stairs
true story
where's Victor Herbert and John runner
now let's see well Jon Renner
is dead Victor Herbert's dead Steven
Barrett is in the basement of his house
and if he's still alive in his desk was
the old door Jonathan they didn't tell
me what they were answering so when you
first discovered that case of cystic
fibrosis working for your keys in the
rhesus monkey I mean I I was a child and
grew up hearing about these stories and
read about them and that doctors don't
lie from your perspective I lived them
as a teenager obviously and it's just
amazing you know just reliving all of
that stuff and then Scott salic was able
to to get some of that very very old
video footage of news stories and you
can still find all of this on you know
Google the original clippings or the
newspaper articles and things but as you
said in that video and you said here
tonight
they fired you for going public with
that information that you believed it to
be you didn't know the term back then or
it didn't exist epigenetics but you you
clearly pointed out to everybody that
you believed it to be more than than
genetics not solely genetics that it was
nutritionally induced and you called out
the specific nutrients back then which
are true today obviously you still hold
it at that today so but they fired you
for that and I I know there was a lot
going on in your your family life at
that time growing up at that time myself
around then and obviously but you kept
going as I said in that video you know
you you've taken some on some major
challenges that would cause most people
to just curl up in a ball and quit do
more than quit you and you know most
people would would absolutely quit but
you kept going
why well again it was to save because
you know you have something that can
save kids you just can't quit and of
course I had saved myself from Harville
disease threat syndrome when I was a kid
started with the symptoms of tread
syndrome when I was four I was disabled
really disabled by the time I was nine
and my mom and dad had taken me to 20
different doctors in the twentieth one
maryjane doctors don't okay health
freedom okay well last 20 years okay
when I was finished she'll always
accuses me of going back too far when I
was fired when I was fired now I just to
make sure you know when I when I made
this discovery I knew that I had
something unusual I looked it up in
human medicine and cystic fibrosis and I
got I got to permission to do biopsies
on the other 24 baby monkeys in that
colony that didn't have any genetic
relationship to that one monkey they
were just the only genetic relationship
they were all monkeys but they weren't
brothers and sisters or cousins or
anything like that every one of them had
a different mother father they're all
the same age and they're raising these
four NASA projects or training these
monkeys to do things and they give him
appellate you know when they do the
right thing and they send them off into
space well I asked for permission to get
a biopsy of those other 24 monkeys and
guess what they all had cystic fibrosis
I knew it was environmental well
fortunately they had saved the blood
from them from the adult monkeys every
month for six years in ten frozen had
just in case something like that had
happened and they had saved them the the
blood every month for the baby monkeys
were now six months old and froze it and
so I had I didn't have to get a grant to
do those things they had already done it
for six years
but nobody had used the materials so I
went back and I only had to do is look
at and say well well here's this one
nutrient this missing and I went back
into the animal industry and said oh
look at that the deficiency that
nutrient causes cystic fibrosis and
animals but they didn't know that's what
it was caused in animals because they
were animal pathologists not people who
is Allah gist and so I took it to the
powers of B they sent it to the highest
experts in pathology around the world
and physical doses they all agreed there
rose's then i told it was a monkey they
got excited at first oh we can do
laboratory animals I say oh yeah how
many one I can make a thousand of them
so what yeah it's not genetic this is
actually just a simple nutritional
deficiency even the genetic markers in
nutritional deficiencies if I give the
nutrition nutrient intravenously the
genetic marker will go in 24 hours if I
give it to him orally the jenk Markel's
ago in two weeks and that's when they
fired me and today the field of
epigenetics is the hottest research
field there is yes and what is
epigenetics I mean you besides your
best-selling book explain it in simple
terms in 30 seconds or less what is 30
seconds less okay well the medical
profession has thousands of failed
medical theories going back thousands
and thousands of years in the 20th
century 21st century is no different and
whenever doctor doesn't know what you
have or he's never seen what you have he
says its genetic or autoimmune or
something like that he just gives it a
name that insurance companies will pay
for he says I don't know insurance
companies won't pay him right so it's
either genetic or autoimmune well it
turns out that your genes DNA RNA and
telomeres only control xx females XY
males
skin color hair color and eye color
other than that genes don't do anything
they don't cause any agencies bad genes
no crazy all the birth defects are
caused by nutritional deficiencies of
the embryo and after 20000 autopsies I
had figured that out
that's my twelve hundred page book and
so when you know this when you know this
you know that you know it and I was
getting calls from the National Health
Federation which is alternative health
group and they were the one that
introduced me of the problems that the
FDA did for people and so forth and they
had me come and lecture and tell my
story and that's when I met that I never
heard of nature I think doctors that's
when I met nature Matic doctors there
let's see the it was in Chicago was in
Chicago and
as one of those things where I was
introduced to a whole new feel because I
was working in hospitals and research
laboratory Clinton Miller yeah over
Clinton Miller dr. Strauss er also a
little later at the same time okay dr.
Strauss er actually was a week first and
he said I want you to come and lecture
at a bunch of Nobel Prize winners with
your stuff because he believed me dr.
Houser believed me
and so that was a great vote of
confidence from dr. Strauss or one of my
heroes
the selenium expert he got his PhD
degree showing that selenium is an
essential nutrient and then Clinton
Miller from the National Health
Confederation Federation I had me
lecture to them in Chicago at the
McCormick Center and that's the first
time I'd lectured to a group this big
and told my story and the nature paddock
staff came said look we want you to
lecture at the nature Pathak school I
mean what are they and now I are one
[Laughter]
so when
when you made that discovery of cystic
fibrosis and the monkey at Yerkes one of
the key nutrients you specifically
called out as one of the keys to this
was a selenium deficiency now this was
in 1977 I believe 77 that's correct they
fired me in 78 okay
and so that's the way I remember it so
but in 1977 1978 selenium was not a
recognized essential nutrient you knew
it was essential but the government the
RDI RDA FDA did not know or recognize
selenium as a essential nutrient today
it's an essential nutrient so your work
dr. Strauss work other people's work but
your life's work contributed to selenium
being a recognized essential nutrient
that's correct
back then the medical system believed
that selenium was one of the worst
toxins in the world they believed it yet
today
you ask you know medical doctor what
about some oil you can have selenium but
it's too toxic you get everything you
need from your food that's like saying
you don't need to put oil in your car
just put dirt from Texas in your car
there's bound to be some oil in it's
dirt from the Texas BAM you're dead you
knew I
[Applause]
okay so in the last year and a half or
so you and Jonathan emore teamed up
again and went back to the FDA in
regards to taking them to school in
regards to selenium and this was in
regards to selenium being a required
nutrient in baby food sold in the United
States it was not a required nutrient to
be put into baby food in the US so baby
foods sold on the Shelf throughout the
US did not contain selenium had pet baby
food puppy puppy well the can know for
pup oh yeah but dog food - yes okay now
but now the FDA recognized the error of
their ways and they have required that
baby formula now contains sold in the US
now contains selenium
now which goes back to your statement
about how important it is when you know
that information in order to protect the
most vulnerable that children the babies
this story gets better
good okay now somewhere I believe was
1989 Milan and I went to China to
Keshawn Province and because we knew
selenium deficiency was was part of this
the syndrome of severe broses cause
there's a disease called Keshawn disease
and Keshawn province China which is
cardiomyopathy heart disease it's that
it's a heart attack that Anthony's died
from the sudden heart death from
athletes and this problem say have
thousands and thousands of kids die
every month from this because this
selenium is not in the soil there and so
I said you know I'm gonna be able to
prove by going to Keshawn promised China
Milan's family set all this up they had
connections hospitals to give me the you
know the bodies and the slides and do
the chemistry and everything I wanted to
do mm automatic 10 that died at Keshawn
disease cardiomyopathy heart disease
because it's a saline deficiency I Salim
deficiency I said you know if I'm
correct there's me some of these Chinese
kids with cystic fibrosis if I could
just find 25 or 30 of them out of 2,000
because it's supposed to be a genetic
disease of Eastern Europeans not of
Asians I could five if I could find 25
kids these Chinese kids with cystic
fibrosis who died of Keshawn disease
heart disease a slim deficiency I'll be
able to make my point well I've failed
they couldn't find 25 I found 595 out of
1,700 fully 35 percent had cystic
fibrosis 100 percent had muscular
dystrophy and 200 under the age of three
months it all died of crib death SIDS
because SIDS is due to a deficiency of
selenium
it's a cardiomyopathy heart attack in
these little babies it's not getting
tangled up in their blankets is
because they suffocated sleeping on
their bellies is not because they were
not sleeping in a cardboard box which is
her newest theory how dumb are these
people okay so what this is gonna do and
what we appreciate because of Steve and
you and Michelle and Richard Renton and
myself and Jonathan E Morton all the
stuff we did to get this into baby farm
look we're going to eliminate SIDS huh
we're going to eliminate ro system
mustard history now here's the the next
horror part of the story we realized
that we could prove that this slim
deficiency also was the cause of mustard
history it's not unusual calcium
deficiency causes 147 different diseases
so to have three or four or five
different diseases caused by Nestle and
division is not unusual and so we gave
the information after working with some
mustard seed kids we were able to help
them eliminate all their symptoms give
their body would have needed to
eliminate their symptoms effectively
they didn't have anymore Alma genetic
markers go away we gave all this
information to Jerry Lewis he took it to
the most traditional foundation in 2011
and they fired Jerry Lewis they stopped
at telethon and somebody needs to go to
jail
[Applause]